right before thanksgiving health
officials were warning everyone to stay
home for the holidays and limit
family gatherings to avoid spreading the
virus now we're learning
dr debra burks traveled out of state
over thanksgiving weekend
with three generations of her family
from two separate households
disregarding her own advice well kane is
a co-host of fox and friends weekend and
he joins us live here in studio jay this
morning happy holidays to you well good
morning merry christmas so is this just
the latest round of
hypocrisy rules for thee not for me
because she traveled to her home she
said she was
going there to winterize it i believe
with her explanation but still members
outside of her
own household three generations two
different families
stunning isn't it it's stunning though
not because of hypocrisy
hypocrisy and politicians go hand in
hand that's coffee and donuts
yes we should be outraged about
hypocrisy but it's all too common
whether or not it's gavin newsom or eric
garcetti or the mayor of denver or the
mayor of austin
it's just all too common what's stunning
sandra is what it reveals
i think it just reels an absolute
disdain for the average
common american out there that they send
messages to americans out there right
now
whose businesses are being shuttered
their livelihoods being lost they're
saying goodbye to loved ones in the
hospital without even
able to go into the hospital think of
the cost
the average american is paying while the
rule makers
the lecturers the elites do not abide by
these rules i think what's stunning is
the absolute
disdain it shows for the american people
it's a this is tough
and you you've had a long list of
democratic lawmakers that
have been accused of hypocrisy because
so many of them laying down these really
tough restrictions
but here's dr burks inside of the
obviously the covid team at the white
house
and she very clearly laid out her own
advice right before thanksgiving
i'm just wondering what are they
thinking people are
exhausted from this we're all trying to
do the right thing we're all trying to
wear our masks social distance
you know only stay within our own
household
but then they break their own advice by
warning how dangerous this
is so of course i'm speculating but
here's my attempt to answer your
question of what are they thinking you
and i spoke about this for a moment on
friday
i believe that the world is now being
divided largely into elites versus the
common man
and i think they see themselves in an
elite status and what comes along with
that elite status is a special
application of the rules now here's how
it really manifests i think
they're smarter than us they can make a
risk calculation that we're not capable
of going governor newsom as we remember
at french laundry
not distance i don't think it's that
newsom doesn't believe his own rules i
think that he believes he's smarter than
me
or you or everyone watching right now to
make a risk calculation about whether or
not
he should be able to bend the rules in
short that disdain i spoke about a
moment ago
he thinks of himself as incredibly
intelligent capable of making a
calculated risk
analysis but we we need to be led by the
nose while we give up that stuff that's
precious to us so here's dr burks in her
own words this is cbs face the nation
this is from november heading into
thanksgiving
listen you need to take it upon yourself
to be restrictive you need to not go to
these places you need to protect your
family now
and really watch if your family traveled
you have to assume that you were exposed
and you became infected and you
really need to get tested in the next
week steve hilton says this yet another
elitist
lockdown hypocrite how dare these people
he writes continue with their cruel
stupid counterproductive lockdown rules
when they don't obey them we are
absolutely sick
of the lot of you says steve hilton so
we sit here and wonder why the american
people have lost trust in institutions
this institution the media academic
institutions
election integrity why are americans so
skeptical of what they are told
from the elites why are they so
skeptical of things that have lasted in
this country for decades
institutions that we used to believe in
why i think we're having it laid out
before us
quite clearly and i think it's very
rational for the american people to go
you know i don't know if everything
they're telling me adds up
yeah and and and i i go back to we're
dealing with
obviously a very serious situation the
pandemic is
still very very serious as it is right
now spikes in many states that we're
still dealing with as we try to roll out
the vaccine
but when you have dr burks saying this
about
limiting to just your household you
really wonder again what they're
thinking here she is on cnn
i'm making the personal sacrifices i
like it to be
keep it to your immediate household
because
you know if you say it can be ten and
it's eight people
from four different families then that
probably
is not the same degree of safe as
10 people from your immediate household
but then she went on to ignore her own
advice she traveled to her
second home with her three generations
of her family
in that one home and we're not saying
that's wrong right
right we're saying that goes against the
health officials
guidance and recommendations that we're
all trying to live by
if we can but she did differently what i
think is we welcome their guidance
and recommendations we reject their
mandates and then we embrace our own
ability to be rational to be smart to
make our risk calculations about whether
or not we can visit our family
or open our business whether or not
we'll take protocols in
into hand and apply them in our lives we
are smart enough
we are not dumber than them we do not
need to defer to them
as they break their own rules you know
and that was of course thanksgiving and
heading into thanksgiving and here we
are christmas is upon us
it's coming up this friday and a lot of
american families are gonna have to make
these really important decisions to keep
themselves to keep their family members
safe
whether or not they decide to travel or
not travel you've already seen the lines
at the airport many are choosing to pack
their bags and go
and i for one trust the american people
to make smart decisions about the safety
of them
their family and their businesses